member
hi I'm Lucy and this is tomorrow and we
have been hands-on with batman arkham
knight so tomorrow we both played all
about mind games yep Rocksteady's what
was the biggest difference you noticed
in Arkham Knight um obviously it's the
thing that the thrusting upon us it's
the Batmobile which is a big big part of
the game most noticeable change and it's
it's I was surprised at how much I
enjoyed using the Batmobile I expected
it to be quite a heavy vehicle like way
more chunky than it actually yeah felt
when you actually played it it's a lot
more nimble yeah III when I was playing
it I was trying to come up with like
equivalent would be like trying it felt
like it should move like the Wraith in
Halo the big tank by actually moves a
bit like a ghost which is in terms of a
can turn on a dime and it's super nippy
like we played one of the missions we
played was the Firefly mission which is
and the character appears and he's kind
of like signified in the game world by
buildings beyond being on fire and
you're supposed to chase him down in the
actual Batmobile and the first thing I
did was because I wasn't expecting it to
be as nimble I just immediately turned
off a bridge and went on down into some
unreachable area immediately lost him
here you expect it to be just this
chunky car all the way through but it's
very easy to negotiate if you get stuck
in a corner because you go into battle
mode and it basically moves on a grid
yeah instead and you can then attack
obviously because Batman doesn't kill if
you ever do attack your its aim your gun
at someone you get you find of like a
non-lethal round which is quite cool and
you can't run people over it's not that
they have superhuman reflexes and just
leap out the way you have you kind of
expel this sort of electromagnetic force
that just gently pushes people that way
yeah there's not a lot of people around
to run away they're mostly thugs but um
yeah I enjoyed how it felt like I was
turning corners without using the brakes
it sometimes it's easier to just use the
going to the battle mode because it
brings you to a much like a quicker stop
and you can also strafe with it so it's
really good to just like boost and then
turn right strafe around the corner and
the thing that I loved about it was um
Batman suit is actually made from
similar materials used in them Batmobile
and
I don't know how they explaining this
but apparently it maintains the cause
momentum his suit does that that's what
I was told so what happens is when you
double tap the X button when you're
moving at speed it just immediately
fires them out and you can use that to
cover long distances and do big jumps
which i'm guessing might be at some
point how he gets across a broken bridge
or something like that but also we used
the Batmobile so the Arkham Knight I
don't know where he's got his money from
but he has enough enough dollar to
basically leave on the tanks around city
of Gotham that you in the Batmobile can
take out it's like a fun little side
mission minigame yes you can see where
they're gonna fire and you can quickly
nip out of the way and destroy them with
the with the back wheel in its armored
tank mode which is quite fun yeah little
distraction yeah it's really clever the
way they do the thing sold each each of
these tanks they fire a tracer and it's
a car man we think it's gold and then it
goes red when it's about to shoot you
say functions just like a like a camera
signifier that the enemies would have
over their heads at the moment it goes
red you know you need to move out of the
way or it will take some damage and each
of these tanks they have a like a blue
spot at the top which is like the turret
area where if you can hit it there it
will blow up in an instant so it's like
quiet there's a skill to kind of dashing
out of damage zones and kind of lining
up shots and pinpointing it d tanks
which is cool i enjoyed it took me a
couple tries to do all go and get
through them but it was fun i enjoyed it
so switch you up to actual you know the
gameplay that we know and love we got to
see the fear takedown yeah in action so
another kind of an example of what it's
similar to would be cool to judy's
breach mechanic so you are the way i did
i was on top of a building it had a
glass roof uh you highlights the enemies
down below and you can
read this so you can attack oh you can
attack three I think in the beginning
and attack normal by spending Wayne
Wayne tech points in the skill tree so
if you're playing and you're you have it
guys you jump down on top of them and it
basically goes into slow-mo and you
attack the first guy then you have time
to just move the camera and highlight
the next guy and press the tag and he'll
go to that and it slows down again you
highlight the next guy and you don't
base achill e train up where I was in
the game you can train at four and then
the last guy crying on his own when you
can just take out in the normal Batman
that's like a cinematic version of the
normal like a small skirmish we're just
in between your movements is kind of
like slowing the action down and letting
you and direct Batman somewhat but I'm
interesting what do you think of the
overall combat because I found it to be
way more chaotic than previous games
well Roxy was saying that in in Arkham
Knight because its next-gen current gen
now I guess we can call it they have the
capability to put more any was on screen
than ever before so it definitely feels
more chaotic and in the one mission we
played we actually got the chance to
switch to Nightwing yeah and he just I
think that's what I love about Arkham's
the ultimate characters is that they
definitely feel different from Batman so
while you are still being the Batman you
can be that gruff aggressive but control
switching to night wing he's just so
much more acrobatic he has his electric
taser that he can get he can spring over
enemies faster train at more kills and
you can do kind of double take down with
both of you guys yeah I found myself
sticking with Batman purely because I
like the like the deal take down because
Nightwing would also like often just
come from above me and like flying kick
into an enemy or something so it was
always something unexpected but yeah
it's I enjoyed switching back and forth
I think it's less of like a ballet than
previous games but it kind of fits into
the way that the the kind of enemies in
Gotham are so desperately just trying to
overwhelm Batman something matically it
makes sense but there's less of like a
kind of finessing and it's more like
crisis management and they've got new
enemy types like these guys who can
counter you and there's also the charges
who you've got keep an eye out for their
always hiding on the like the periphery
of the arena and then they'll just
no we're just charging at you and you've
got like really instinctively get over
him so yeah it still it still has that
adrenaline rush and the kind of like
timing based combat that everyone loves
from the previous two games but it's
just at the same time it's on such a
bigger scale and it's more manic and
they're just so much more to see and do
it's yeah I'm very excited about it yeah
me too I always expected it to be a good
game like The Rock said you have knocked
out of the park twice but so I wasn't
expecting it would be any worse than the
previous two games but I still yet to be
seen how good it is weather is gonna be
like as we have moments like the Arkham
City ending where it's kind of like mind
blowing all the across the famous dr.
free classified yep exactly we did ask
him about that and they were quick to
point out that the guy that designed it
is still out rock steady and he is doing
school working on some great stuff yeah
he's yeah he's quick to point out that
he made that boss fight and he wants
everyone to know that he's still there
so my have some surprises yeah so our
command is obviously coming out in june
for more coverage make sure you keep big
game spot